hilfe mit hintergedanken
bundesinnenminister seehofer sagt bis zu
150 minderjährige aus moriya dürfen
kommen
er verlangt aber auch eine europäische
lösung absatzkrise bei ma n der lkw
hersteller will bis zu 9500 stellen
streichen und flucht vor dem feuer an
der us-westküste breiten sich die
waldbrände unkontrolliert aus
hunderttausende haben ihre häuser
verloren
die nachrichten sich das heute mit
christian sievers und abend hinein und
herzlich willkommen an diesem
nachrichten freitag kristin otto hat
nachher den blick auf den sportler und
einen radsport krimi guten abend es ist
nur eine kleine zahl von flüchtlingen
die aus dem völlig ausgebrannten lager
moria auf lesbos in andere europäische
staaten gebracht werden sollen insgesamt
400 minderjährige von dort deutschland
wird davon 100 bis 150 aufnehmen der
bundesinnenminister spricht heute von
einem ersten schritt in moria selbst
soll ein neues camp entstehen
das alte wie es hier zu sehen ist gibt
es nicht mehr moria vor und nach dem
brand mit dem feuer hatten die etwa
12.000 600 bewohner auch das nötigste
verloren
ein dach über dem kopf
waschgelegenheiten lebensmittel und
medikamente
seit drei tagen bleibt vielen zum
schlafen nur der straßenrand bilder die
sich auch auf die diskussion in berlin
heute auswirken andrea es ist das erste
statement des innenministers seit den
bränden in moria und seehofer macht klar
aus deutschland kommt erstmal nur eine
kleine geste 100 bis 150 minderjährige
will die bundesregierung noch diesen
monat aufnehmen mehr deutsches
engagement gäbe es nur im europäischen
verbund ein isoliertes handeln hatte
auch die ganz große gefahr des pool
effektes haben wir alles schon mal
erlebt dass sich eben dann alle auf
diesen staat zu bewegen der allein
handelt und wir haben uns ja alle
vorgenommen dass sich das jahr 2015
nicht wiederholen darf
400 kinder und jugendliche gelte es nun
zu verteilen so seehofer nur 10 von 27
eu-staaten haben sich bereit erklärt die
eu-kommission sich hat jetzt vor allem
hilfe beim wiederaufbau des lagers zu
die eu sei bereit sagt der zugeschaltete
vizepräsident nicht nur den bau eines
neuen zentrums zu finanzieren und zu
unterstützen sondern auch auf bitten der
griechen hin eine aktivere rolle im
management dieser einrichtung zu
übernehmen
gegen mittag dann auftritt seehofers vor
einem erhitzten parlament die afg
spricht von zitat schein flüchtlingen
und wega keine menschen aus moriya
aufnehmen was hier not tut ist
konsequent grenzen schützen migranten
abweisen illegale abschieben dann kommen
keine mehr keine überfüllten lager keine
brände keine mittel mehr toten die linke
wiederum kritisiert dass seehofer
kommunen verbieten noch mehr flüchtlinge
aufzunehmen
auch die 150 die jetzt aufnehmen wollen
ändern daran ehrlich gesagt überhaupt
nichts hier agieren ist nicht christlich
hier agieren ist unmenschlich
für den 30 september hat der
innenminister nun einen gemeinsamen asyl
pakt mit europa angekündigt erste
arbeitstreffen sollen nächste woche
stattfinden bringen wir theo koll mit in
unsere sendung an diesem freitag her und
nahmen nach berlin da geht es natürlich
und in erster linie um die lösung eines
humanitären problems aber man kann auch
den eindruck bekommen dass in der
berliner politik taktische erwägungen
mitbestimmen ja die bestimmen ja leider
in ganz europa die migrationspolitik mit
und berlin macht da keine ausnahme es
geht absurderweise um die
aufrechterhaltung von druck und zwar auf
die anderen aufnahme unwilligen
europäischen partner denn so jedenfalls
die argumentation hier wenn die
bundesrepublik jetzt das problem
quasi im alleingang löst dann lehnen
sich die anderen zurück und müssen sich
nicht weiter mit dem thema einer
gemeinsamen europäischen asylpolitik
beschäftigen mit dieser begründung
wurden ja auch schon hilfsangebote
einiger bundesländer abgelehnt und die
zweite überlegung ist stärker
innenpolitisch wenn horst seehofer sagt
2015 dürfe sich nicht wiederholen
das nehme er sehr ernst meint er zwar
einerseits einen deutschen alleingang in
europa aber auch den ausgelösten aufwind
für extrem rechte gegenbewegungen
hierzulande und den vorwand will man auf
keinen fall erneut bieten
danke für diese analyse theo koll in
berlin
und wie die situation nach wie vor ist
vor ort in moria und wie sehr sie drängt
das zeigt jetzt annette hilsenbeck am
nachmittag gehen sie auf die straße
menschen die in moria gehaust haben
jetzt ob nach
die stimmung ist explosiv polizei steht
bereit
sie wollen ihre lage nicht mehr
hinnehmen sie konstruieren jetzt ein
neues camp in dem supermarkt aber wir
wollen nicht hier bleiben wir wollen
griechenland verlassen
seit dem morgen baut die griechische
armee auf einem militärgelände ein neues
zeltlager auf es heißt dass hier einige
tausend menschen untergebracht werden
könnten
die versorgung die kam funktionierte
seit ein großbrand das lager maria
zerstörte läuft ebenfalls an
lastwagenweise verteilen die
griechischen behörden essen und trinken
an die migranten tausende versuchen sich
einigermaßen zu schützen so etwas wie
ein dach über dem kopf zu haben doch die
situation der migranten ist auch am tag
drei nach dem brand chaotisch einen
weiteren langen tag haben tausende
menschen hier unter freiem himmel
verbracht es fehlen sanitäre
einrichtungen sauberes trinkwasser
männer frauen und vor allem kinder haben
hier nichts sie brauchen dringend
humanitäre nothilfe
heute morgen hat die griechische
regierung die polizeikräfte auf der
insel verstärkt polizisten bewachen die
straße zum hafenort mittellinie sollen
verhindern dass migranten die insel
verlassen
zudem gibt es aufrufe unter den
bewohnern von lesbos sie sind wütend
weil die regierung das camp moria wieder
aufbauen will blockieren die
zufahrtsstraße wir wollen umgehende
entlastung und dass das lager
geschlossen hat es ist letztlich eine
gute gelegenheit das lager zu schließen
wir haben genug gelitten all die jahre
sie aber brauchen eine bleibe noch immer
harren auf lesbos tausende menschen im
freien aus in die deutsche innenpolitik
interessenvertreter werben bei
politikern für ihre sache das passiert
dauert normalerweise erfährt die
öffentlichkeit aber nichts davon
heute berät der bundestag über ein
lobbyregister dass mehr transparenz
schaffen soll in das für jeden
einsehbare verzeichnis müssten sich alle
lobbyisten eintragen und zwar nicht nur
wenn sie abgeordnete kontaktieren
sondern auch und das ist das neue wenn
sie sich direkt an die regierung wenden
bei verstößen würde eine geldbuße bis zu
50.000 euro fällig
und damit in der sendung zum thema
corona gucken wir uns zunächst die
zahlen an und die sind bei uns in
deutschland relativ konstant im schnitt
der vergangenen sieben tage haben sich
täglich 1330 menschen neu angesteckt
gestern lag der schnitt bei 1290 ganz
anders dagegen die lage in vielen
gebieten in südwesteuropa auf mallorca
machen die behörden wegen gestiegener
infektionszahlen teile der hauptstadt
palma dicht die bewohner eines
stadtviertels außerhalb des historischen
zentrums dürfen dieses ab heute 22 uhr
nur noch verlassen um zur arbeit zu
gehen zur schule oder zum arzt
betroffen sind rund 23.000 menschen die
ausgangs beschränkung gilt zunächst für
zwei wochen und frankreich meldet seit
tagen enorme zahlen von neuinfektionen
zuletzt innerhalb von 24 stunden fast
10.000 neue fälle so viele wie noch nie
zuvor
die regierung fordert alle franzosen nun
noch einmal eindringlich auf die regeln
einzuhalten
noch will sie grundsätzlich an ihrer
corona strategie festhalten der
premierminister sagt ein neuer
landesweiter lockdown sei nicht geplant
allerdings bekämen lokale behörden
größere befugnisse um zum beispiel die
öffnungszeiten von geschäften zu
reduzieren
für uns in paris christel haas christel
kein neuer lockdown also für frankreich
aber ein heftiger appell des premiers
wird die regierung damit die steigenden
zahlen in den griff bekommen können
das ist schon das prinzip hoffnung dass
der premierminister hkex wohin
durchgedrungen ist und durchgedrungen
ist
denn einen nationalen lockern kann sich
frankreich ganz leisten das wäre eine
katastrophe für die wirtschaft und so
war es vor allem ein eindringlicher
appell sich doch bitte strikt an die
vorhandenen maßnahmen zu halten ohne
solidarität sagte cass tags können wir
das virus nicht bekämpfen
das geld russland ist er fast die hälfte
des landes gilt mittlerweile als
risikozonen 42 département es sind zwar
vor allem noch die junge leute die sich
anstecken aber den krankenhäuser steigen
die zahlen wieder die patientenzahlen
und da sind es vor allem wieder die
älteren leute die eingeliefert werden so
wie damals im frühjahr die quarantäne
die 14-tägige wird von den franzosen
nämlich meistens nicht eingehalten wenn
sie kontakt zu infizierten hatten oder
wenn sie einen positiven test habe und
so wird sie jetzt auf sieben tage
verkürzt aber ob diese korrekturen
ankommen und vor allem ob der appell von
premierminister aspekt die franzosen
wirklich erreicht das ist alles andere
als sicher
strenge regeln in frankreich wir sehen
es herzlichen dank christa haas in paris
unser nächstes thema von der
us-westküste erreichen uns apokalyptisch
anmutende bilder dort oben die
schwersten waldbrände in der geschichte
der region
es brennt von mexiko bis kanada in
kalifornien stand noch nie eine so
riesige fläche in flammen
in oregon fliehen hunderttausende vor
den vier wänden und auch im bundesstaat
washington sind viele ortschaften von
der außenwelt abgeschnitten britta jäger
berichtet nie zuvor waren die feuer an
der us-westküste so groß so
zerstörerisch
allein in kalifornien haben die flammen
mehr als 12.500 quadratkilometer land
zerstört ein erschreckender rekord rund
14.000 einsatzkräfte kämpfen bis zur
erschöpfung
ja die hier gerade wüten sind
beispiellos selbst für die ältesten und
erfahrensten leute in unserem team das
so genannte august komplex feuer in
nordkalifornien ist mittlerweile zum
größten brand der westküsten geschichte
herangewachsen
im nachbarstaat oregon mussten eine
halbe million menschen ihre häuser
verlassen und sich in sicherheit bringen
bei den rückkehrern herrscht pure
verzweiflung
das ist was übrig geblieben ist nur dass
insgesamt 15 menschen sind an der
westküste bereits gestorben die
offizielle totenzahl könnte noch steigen
viele ortschaften sind durch feuerwände
von der außenwelt abgeschnitten
die ungeheuerlichkeit dieser feuer deren
umfang intensität und zerstörung das ist
beispiellos auch in der geschichte des
staates washington trockene wälder sind
futter für die flammen starke winde
fachen sie immer weiter an
die feuerwehr kämpft eine gigantische
schlacht und die waldbrandsaison hat
gerade erst begonnen
unfassbare bilder heute ist der elfte
september der tag der vor 19 jahren die
welt veränderte islamisten ermordeten in
den usa mit vier entführten flugzeugen
etwa 3000 menschen mitten im wahlkampf
veränderten beide bewerber um das
präsidentenamt heute an die opfer donald
trump in einer feier in shanksville
pennsylvania
dort hatten die terroristen die vierte
maschine zum absturz gebracht nachdem
deren passagiere sich gegen die
attentäter gewährt hatten
joe biden gedachte in new york der toten
an der stelle wo damals das world trade
center zerstört wurde in russland finden
derzeit im halben land regionalwahlen
statt und spätestens seit der vergiftung
des kreml kritikers alexej nawalny
wartet auch das ausland gespannt aufs
ergebnis
ohnehin geht es in der bevölkerung
corona die schlechte wirtschaftliche
lage und eine unpopuläre rentenreform
haben die kreml partei in umfragen
rapide absacken
für begann berichtet durchstochener
autoreifen und anfeindungen konnten zehn
jahre vdi war nicht von ihrem plan
abbringen
sie gehört zum team des oppositionellen
alexej nawalny und kandidiert für das
tosca stadtparlament die sozialen gräben
zwischen arm und reich sind monströs
besorgniserregend und besonders
auffallend in den provinzstädten die
regierungspartei einiges russland muss
mit mehr gegenwind rechnen als sie
gewohnt ist bei diesen wahlen von
gouverneuren regional und stadt
abgeordneten der rubel verliert an wert
präsident putin an zustimmung und im
osten russlands wird seit monaten
protestiert ernüchterung auf den straßen
klar die wahlen sind wichtig sie bringen
den volkswillen zum ausdruck trotz der
fälschungen und dem ausschluss von
kandidaten können die menschen so
wenigstens etwas unternehmen wenn ich
meine stimme gebe habe ich noch nicht
entschieden
aber eines ist sicher ich möchte nicht
für die regierungspartei stimmen ich
hätte gerne eine alternative um für eine
alternative zu werben war alexej nawalny
mitte august nach tomsk gereist er trete
ein enthüllungs video beschuldigte die
kommunalpolitik der korruption
wenn man durch eine spezialbrille schaut
sieht man dass die ganze stadt von den
spinnen weben der korruption umwickelt
ist auf dem rückweg aus tomsk viel
navalny ins koma seine vergiftung im
eigenen land in der eigenen stadt das
habe einige gegen die regierung
aufgebracht meint xenia vde ob sich das
im wahlverhalten widerspiegelt wird das
wochenende zeigen zurück nach
deutschland im zusammenhang mit den
missbrauchsfällen da gladbach sind zwei
angeklagte zu hohen haftstrafen
verurteilt worden
das landgericht mönchengladbach
entschied die beiden männer müssen für
13 einhalb und 14 eineinhalb jahre
hinter gitter wegen schweren sexuellen
kindesmissbrauchs sowie besitzes und
verbreitung kinderpornografischer
schriften
die verteidiger kündigten an das urteil
anzufechten
und jetzt geht es um die zukunft der
automobilbranche gleich zwei wichtige
nachrichten heute aus dem
volkswagen-konzern
seit heute ist das neue elektroauto von
vw auf deutschlands straßen unterwegs
und der lkw bauer man
will massiv stellen abbauen das
traditionsunternehmen gehört wie viele
andere bekannte marken zum volkswagen
konzern
hermann will den sparkurs verschärfen
und 9500 stellen streichen viele davon
in deutschland und österreich
möglicherweise sollen auch
produktionsstandorte geschlossen werden
mehr von alexander pohl
die ankündigung löste im ganzen
unternehmen schockwellen aus von fast
einem viertel der belegschaft will sich
der münchener lkw und bushersteller
trennen
nicht erst seit corinna kämpf t en mit
einer schwachen nachfrage
gleichzeitig braucht man milliarden für
notwendige investitionen
ziel der neuausrichtung ist es immer and
rock and bass digitaler automatisierter
und profitabel zu machen
auf basis heutiger technologien und
strukturen wird ein erfolgreiches
geschäftsmodell in wenigen jahren kaum
mehr möglich sein
schon mitte des jahrzehnts will ma n zu
den führenden herstellern im bereich
elektro und wasserstoff antriebe gehören
ein ziel mit folgen die transformation
hin beispielsweise zur elektromobilität
bedeutet dass ungefähr 30 prozent
weniger mitarbeiter gebraucht werden
insofern wird das ziel nicht erreichbar
sein jeden arbeitsplatz tatsächlich zu
erhalten
standorte wie plauen in sachsen oder
wittlich in rheinland pfalz könnten
geschlossen werden
eine hiobsbotschaft für die mitarbeiter
die hat uns natürlich erst mal getroffen
wie ein schlag
weil wir wussten eigentlich gar nichts
na ja auch besonders gut ist die
stimmung nicht also die motivation würde
ich sagen ist gesunken
die ig metall wirft ma n missmanagement
vor und pocht auf eine vereinbarung die
betriebsbedingte kündigungen ausschließt
für uns ist noch mal ganz wichtig dass
wir keine kündigung akzeptieren werden
es gibt genug möglichkeiten die wir in
deutschland kennen wir die anzahl der
arbeitsplätze sozialverträglich
reduzieren können
über die wird in den kommenden wochen
hart verhandelt werden
ganz hat schon gehört die zukunft der
autobranche liegt in der e mobilität und
stabil vw jetzt zum großen wurf ansetzen
mit seinem neuen e auto id 3
die ersten fahrzeuge wurden heute an die
kunden übergeben das soll ein
verkaufsschlager werden
aber bisher sind die zahlen in
deutschland überschaubar nur rund neun
prozent aller zugelassenen pkw dieses
jahr waren elektroautos anja chalet
berichtet das soll er werden der neue
volks stromer der id 3
das erste voll elektrische auto von vw
bei der auslieferung in dresden ein
angebot dass marktanteile erobern soll
deswegen haben wir eben auch den id3 so
aufgesetzt dass der zum einstiegspreis
für unter 30.000 erhältlich sein wird da
können sie jetzt nur eineinhalb tausend
fast förderung abziehen dann liegt es
schon mal unter dem vergleichbaren golf
die reichweite beträgt laut branchen
test durchschnittlich 350 kilometer
weniger als von vielen kunden erhofft
der motor hat umgerechnet 204 ps 25.000
fahrzeuge hat volkswagen in europa
bereits verkauft 7000 in deutschland das
problem dass es hierzulande kein
flächendeckendes ladesystem gibt die
zahl der ladestationen und auch
insbesondere der schnellladestationen
muss noch wesentlich erhöht werden sonst
werden die leute auf die elektroautos
eigentlich am besten passen die
stadtbewohner dann werden diese
fahrzeuge nicht relevant werden
mehr als 20.000 ladestationen gibt es in
deutschland insgesamt
nordrhein-westfalen baden-württemberg
und bayern liegen von mecklenburg
vorpommern hat nur wenig möglichkeiten
und auch an den autobahnen gibt es
nachholbedarf der id 3 kommt wochen
später als erwartet auf den markt und
die software probleme die es noch immer
gibt sollen in den kommenden monaten per
update korrigiert werden der erste id3
besitzer kommt übrigens aus passau und
fährt auch dorthin zurück eine säule zum
nach laden hat er sich vorher schon
gesucht
hoffentlich so gut angekommen
wir fahren jetzt rüber zum sport die
dreizehnte etappe der tour de france
190 km sieben bergwertungen im
zentralmassiv das härteste teilstück und
nach einer unglaublich spannenden
endphase steil und knüppelhart sichert
sich der kolumbianer daniel martinez den
tagessieg ganz knapp vor zwei starken
deutschen lennart kenner und maximilian
schach man zeigt ein beherztes solo am
vorletzten anstieg besitzt da eine halbe
minute vorsprung auf teamkollege lennart
kemna und den kolumbianer daniel
martinez die straße zum thie marie im
zentralmassiv ist bis zu 15 prozent
steilen martinez muss alleine die lücke
zu fahren kemna konnte kraft sparen wagt
einen ersten antritt der konkurrent
pariert ihn
sie sind die letzten drei aus einer
ausreißergruppe der zahlenmäßigen
vorteil der beiden deutschen ist dahin
als schach man die kräfte verlassen die
letzten meter zum ziel auf knapp 1600
metern höhe
kemna tritt an aber dann ist martinez
der stärkere
etappensieg für den bergspezialisten die
beiden deutschen haben alles versucht
aber er war der bessere
natürlich haben wir heute gezeigt dass
das slowenische duo roger und poker
chernin titelverteidiger banal wertvolle
sekunden ab gut möglich dass der
kolumbianer dieser tour schon vor den
alpen verloren hat roth erhält gelb sein
junger landsmann poker ist schon zweiter
ein sieg trennt alexander zverev noch
von seinem ersten grand slam finale in
knapp drei stunden geht es los in new
york bei den us open bei denen sich
serena williams endlich den traum vom
insgesamt 24 grand-slam-triumph erfüllen
wollte aber es war auch im neunten
anlauf nicht möglich wiktoria assarenka
nutzt den ersten matchball mit einem ass
doch nach williams einspruch muss die
technik den ersten einzug in ein grand
slam finale seit sieben jahren für die
31 jährige weiß wo sie erst noch
bestätigen
serena williams hat zunächst wenig mühe
gewinnt den ersten satz 6 zu 1 danach
geht nicht mehr viel assarenka früher
mal weltranglisten-erste spielt mutig
und holt die nächsten beiden sätze
jeweils mit 6 zu 3
williams von achilles beschwerden
geplagt scheitert erneut bei dem versuch
ihren 24 grand slam titel zu holen
azarenka bestreitet das finale am
samstag gegen die japanerin naomi
busacca gerade spielt laura siegemund im
damendoppel um den us- open-sieg ersten
satz gewonnen
danke christin zum schluss noch ein
weltrekord der einem den atem verschlägt
hier sehen wir die brasilianerin mayra
auf der höchsten welle die jemals von
einer frau gesurft wurde 22 meter 40 das
war schon im februar in mazar-e in
portugal aber dann mussten erstmal
wissenschaftlern um die wälle exakt zu
vermessen und deren ergebnis gibt es
erst jetzt weltrekord angesichts der
bilder wird auch die weltrekordlerin
nachdenklich sie sagt rückblickend habe
ich mehr riskiert als sich normalerweise
gerne tue eine vorsichtige normalerweise
das wetter erwartet uns eine hitzewelle
beim wetter in den nächsten tagen mehr
gleich von ist intel und der kollege
claus kleber hat das heute-journal den
neuesten stand der dinge um 22 uhr wir
sind morgen wieder da für sie bis dann
aber erst in allen einen angenehmen
abend
[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter eine neue
kaltfront zieht auf bringt aber nur dem
norden etwas regen und auch kaum
abkühlung ansonsten wird es in den
nächsten tagen immer heißer werden das
liegt an einem neuen hoch was sich hier
etabliert in der nacht klart es auf die
sterne funkeln
ansonsten bildet sich im süden nebel in
gewässernähe an der donau und am
bodensee
bei temperaturen bis sieben grad in der
norddeutschen tiefebene und 14 grad im
südwesten deutschlands
morgen scheint die sonne ganz im westen
vom saarland über den main bis zur oder
ganz im süden gibt es noch nebel aus der
nacht er löst sich dann allmählich auf
nach nordwesten gibt es mehr wolken und
an der nordsee durchaus einzelne schauer
und der wind weht kräftig aus west teils
stürmisch temperaturen erreichen bis zu
30 grad schon mal im südwesten 29 im
rhein-main-gebiet 27 richtung sachsen
anhalt und 18 grad an der nordsee
temperaturen steigen weiter an am
sonntag bis 30 viel sonne am montag bis
32 grad und mit 35 grad sind wir fast am
ende der fahnenstange für mitte
september ein schöner abend